i'm gonna hop in there's still an hour
to go
yeah i'm gonna play some bullet
hello romeo you're new yes i see it
first time chatter
all right
this is
the weekly bullet arena
this is black and a bite on c4 is the
question
i want e4
i want i want to get at the
i'm
king
break down this strong point
and drive the night away
this and then that but i don't want to
give up
d5
so
so fast
i had the fork
second chance
still there
still there
still there
all right i'll take now
knight's under control
okay
ah thanks mickey yeah that's it's a tall
task getting to 2900 i've never hit that
this isn't the way to get to 2900 either
playing in these tournaments you really
have to just enter the pool and
go up against
a strong player
for many for many games
okay
i guess i'll take
all it takes i have this
and put the
the unopposed
b
on the long diagonal
how wonderful is it
where's the
nikon all right let's pivot there
a5 b5
should be winning a pawn now
i'm gonna track down that guy
um okay
no stopping the bonnie all right
thank you 907 cold snap yeah that's
right winning stacks
very generous
gifting you a sub
glad you like the
the badge
the one month subscriber badge
we'll go with the slippery snake
ooh
aggression
this feels like someone who's much
higher rated than 15
79
you don't play these moves
that fast do you
i guess
feels stronger than the average 1500
i have the night covering that as well
so there's no double piece sacrifice
yeah
i also do this one
than that
okay
let's get rid of this night
i gotta go faster
sneak in on the dark squares
watch out for stalemate bishop there i
couldn't capture
okay
simo
all right you got to 2100 rapid
you say
because the content on youtube
great to read that man
awesome that's a nice mark
2100
am i able to get an e4
i am
let's be a maneuver
heating up
this guy's not playing
i think i went upon
let me hold off here
stop bishop f5
check first and then there
all right i think they thought i was
gonna take with the
bishop first maybe
not sure
uh how long am i going today not not
much longer um
the rest of this tournament and then uh
i'm probably just gonna hang out in the
chat
i can't string stream for
for very long
i'm gonna keep that open
i'll go here right now
i'll keep e7 open for my queen knight
i'll go here now
i don't want to capture the night i want
to drive the night away
i get some space queen side
i'll hop in now
keep that covered
now i'm looking at this and then that
this rook is almost dead
this night is almost dead
knight isn't going anywhere or the rook
isn't going anywhere excuse me
i guess i'll take it whoa why didn't i
take the queen
i had the queen
what am i doing
oh man
yeah that was a freebie
take free queens
okay there might be b5 don't pre-move
that
okay
queen a5
oh i was like okay i'm all right if my
d-pawn is captured
didn't have to be
seemo you're referencing the beginning
to master playlist that's great news man
i put a lot of time into that and
haven't updated it in a while
but um i'm glad it's it's paid off for
you
awesome awesome awesome
maybe i could have uh
i don't know
where's that night going
slither into the dark
slither
my moment to pounce they're a little off
balance
okay
i resigned
oh yeah is it achievable it's
it's it's gonna be tough you know that i
don't it's achievable sure
2300 but um
yeah you definitely encounter these
these points in your
in your journey where even gaining 50
points is a
can really be a tall task
so
as an example
um i would like to get to
um
i'd like to i'd like to let's say get to
2850 blitz i haven't hit 200 yet
but just getting that next 50
is
not so easy
i think i want to keep
the structure as is
i don't really not a great fan of being
in this
pin so i'd like to have it resolved
that's why i'm taking with the bishop
here
and i might as well take with the queen
i have this covered
queen stands well i wanna go queenside
i could rely upon the queen's post on e5
for at least a move
and let's drift towards the queen side
and second thought let's oh i'm ready to
blunder my queen
yikes
oh
under their queen
okay down on time
do i ever plan to try for fm
uh no i
i've been asked something like that with
uh regarding
i am norms
too
if i play back and
if i go back to playing otb
it would just be to play i don't i don't
have any goal
i think it's a healthy pawn that i'm up
right now
it's not easily tracked
convenient defender
ready to take twice maybe we should have
played this instead of castles
let me try this one
mess up the structure
um
i'm being fancy there
i don't know what i really gained by
doing that
should be winning either way okay
the difference if you don't play
professionally started quite late
now there's examples of players who've
started late
still do well
but for sure you know you start you
start younger
there is a
can have an easier time
this is all clogged up
i'll keep this pawn around control the
night
oh you know what let me take with the
queen
this is appealing
queen f7 g7
queen doesn't even have a move
none of these could really even move
just seeing
that's because of the iron grip
the iron grip knight
there's more to it than that
but uh
there's a strong configuration
all right 46 to go
gagarin
e4
carol khan
bishop out
stop this bishop g4
and here we are
a struggling light square bishop
be welcome to the queen exchange
have the a file
knight on c5 should be good
promote a pawn in the process
track down the better bishop
and another pawn of advance progress
hop in here
let's hang on to that guy
could challenge him right away if he
goes there
back rank mates
hmm bad decision by me
i'm not sure what that was about
okay
i was behind on the clock with that one
okay table let's try the caro khan
ah thanks see simo
continued success
hmm
to be careful
i don't know if this is such a wonderful
idea what i'm doing
oh
they missed that i was on that piece
let's hang on everything
all right
i don't even know what i'm doing with
this knight
i'm just making a forward move
threatening zip
it's not like i'm threatening g2 or f3
ship d2 is a little awkward
this guy
problem
i don't want to take it
circle in
there we'll go here circling f4
is the plan
knight on b4 would be nice
there's another path
that puts pressure on the blockade
and ties one of the pieces down
to defending
i'm pointing at h2 so that could
be a thing
also this idea
it's tough to stop
this knight's under control
let me control the knight first
and this
case there's pressure here
let me force the queen exchange
or not
got these pawn breaks under control
no stalemates
okay
who's in first
andre
i'm allowed to play e4
let's go with this
um
i'm not really sure what i'm doing here
why am i taking with the pawn
get out of the pin oh why am i not
taking that pawn
how many chances do i want
there
finally took that guy
i think it was up for grabs for a bit
okay
sloppy game
uh
i could have played that better
now let's challenge that guy right away
looking forward to a tempo against the
queen
let's go with that for
pawn storm
like g6
you wouldn't dare do it okay hang on
let's try this
can't take with the okay hang on
i'm just losing
i got a jumpy night a hungry night
that was a move too
okay
it's just
what i was just making one defensive
move after another
okay
a happy hopping night yes exactly
pk4787 i missed that one thank you for
the prime sub
appreciate it man
etf
how's that defended okay
i want a light square bishop exchange
knight on f5
i have this secure
take the pawn of bishop h3
keep the pressure
i have a an iron grip over the light
squares
safeguard everything
okay they're down on time
um
provoking e5 i think was winning
a couple moves after that
that knight on d5 was too good
yearly blitz tomorrow
yeah no i don't know
yeah no i don't know
let's go with this
i want to get out of this pin
it's not with check
almost stalemate
had a square
did a little more calculating along that
in that game than i normally would
sharp
i'll get the space
let me immediately work on these f5
squares
f5 g4
okay there's a check that could hit
still though this knight and bishop are
dead
i want to put both knights there really
i don't want a castle
take towards the
center let's go with this first let's
contest this file there's a there's
multiple paths
into b4 g4 excuse me
maybe before i abandon these squares i
want to cancel out a forward move
i could i could have looked to kill the
knight
b4
that was a move as well
let me try for it i don't want this in
between here
okay
there's a light square grip a light
square strategy there
cairo
gotta challenge the trio
pressure there
almost ready to win upon
could take if bishop takes
is on that square still shoot for it
on the bishop
and the rogue
oops
my knight's dead
got the flight square
these passers
should be careful
let me swipe this pawn
check first then here
not seeing a mate
no stalemates
still got the pawnees
okay
birdo
see
i don't want a castle
that night is so annoying
and track this pawn down
bishop on e3
okay
um
we're there
15th
i did try to play king b6 there play
king b6 there
there's a
the wild queen rook pawn attack
i just went up on
i think i did
trying these tricks man
classic time burner
classic
my knight secures that
sneaky pawn
not easy
oh man
oh let's nab this pawn rook is going to
get tracked down
yeah try and get that pawn
oh there's a check
they didn't go for it
should probably start running with my
h-pawn
maybe this should have been in there
already
bishop has this covered
still got another pawn
okay
only 20 minutes remaining
thanks chest pawn
that's right play knight d2
that would have been bad
that holds up the queen side play
i could have captured and then captured
on f5
try this
knight on g3 before g5 that way there's
no h5
guard the f5 square
got a passer
f7
okay
so i'll be able to carve my way in there
thanks mickey it's gonna end at some
point did you did you just jinx me
tough cookie here has my number
bishop b5 might have been a move
i don't know what we're supposed to do
here
it's running a fork
finally got something here
ah
ah
oh i'm down on time
oh
okay
i should have been able to win that at
the end i had a nice time lit time lead
neither one of us knew how to improve
hmm let's try this
quick assault
that isn't working
i don't think
not my day 4.
i'll take
let me get rid of the bishop before it
kills me
fancy
really fancy move
wow
so nice
i have to be prepared to run
crawling up into a ball technique
whoo what a shot b4 that was really nice
taking advantage of that pin on the
third rank
all right let's go cairo
what's that guy doing
um
i guess i'll try this one
play against this put my knight on f4
i should have captured the knight
all right
i'm not quite prepared for that
poison phone
okay knight on this square is good too
don't forget about that one
there we go
hang on
i want to keep the knight
oh you bugger
you bugger
whoa
to help mate
thought that felt a little weird
that was the remain the the final square
taken away from the king
okay this is healthy
around the h-bomb
i'm not taking the knight because this
guy has a wonderful square i could draw
a line
pressure there
defense
pressure
pushing i could have captured there
hang on hang on hang on that one's up
for grabs
push the passer or take here even
take here
defending my queen
queen on d6 it's a
bunch of stuff queen e6 check
okay
11 to go
fetcherman
light squares
bishop on c5
hang on
something really close bye
here it is
that fork on g3 was looming
no stalemates
all right
top 10 at least
for now
i gave the knight the b6 square
how to make progress
oh just gave up that pawn
i could have captured here
mine time
oh
oh there's that one
done
oh
that's a that one stings
[Laughter]
that's the pack leader too
ah when the rook went to the eighth rank
i could have captured the bee pun and we
would have exchanged queenside
queenside pawns
i missed my opportunity
i needed to take that
now eight pounds pinned
yeah
probably shouldn't have
castled so soon
can i take that b-pawn nope
maybe bishop was better
not sure what's being threatened
just in case i don't know
okay
felt some pressure there on my king side
surge
really guess
stop mate
everything's covered
stop the knight jump
now open up the a file
low knight e2
bishop there shouldn't be winning the
race
let's get off of a dark square
watch out for stalemates
oh that was really close i think a
couple times i was ready to make a
stalemating move
nice to stay in the top ten
one more game
final game
oh my goodness
they could have just
landed a fork there
we both blundered seriously
seriously we blundered
we blundered seriously
[Laughter]
what does that even mean
let's reinforce the dark squares
like this i want to keep
a grip over
b4
if i do this that move
but now this i have this
i could have also won that pawn
myra could come back
just in the nick of time
no stalemates
just as
the tourney ends where do we end
ninth
all right i'll take it
a half tournament 225 in there andre
strong opponent
end up with 106.
all right
fun as usual
got my bullet fix in there
good games all
you